you go to churches today you see
somebody kneeling and dancing and
singing and you see Orthodox Jews that
take live chickens and put them over
their head just like we have the Mormons
have you heard this argument hey baby
did you just fart because you blew me
away
believe it or not it was over too much
mayonnaise on it sounds there are many
signs of the day of Judgment of the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him told us about that are coming
crew in front of our eyes maybe they
have some leaders also who are you know
promoting this
my daughter today texted me she's in
Minneapolis she's 19.
and she said
mom is there is this it they all came
they all came true it wasn't like maybe
five out of five no 100 out of four
hundred wake up there are over 300
million Americans that don't know what
Islam is this is why we are opening the
dean Center the first of its kind 35
000 square foot dawa Center and Masjid
to show America the Beautiful Message of
Islam inshallah with your help and
donations we could close on the property
launch Nationwide dowel programs a
state-of-the-art Production Studio for
online content and an on-site dawa
Center to show what true Islam is donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
and greetings of Peace welcome to the
dean show which is a way of life
we try to put out there for everyone to
see helping you
understand Islam and Muslims
which is the by the way the most
misunderstood way of life yet the
fastest growing way of life in the world
even though there are billions being
spent by the Hate Machine to keep you
and Humanity away from it
it's very easy to understand very
logical evidence-based and my next guest
really likes to bring the evidence and
many times even from the Bible out of
his love for Jesus he really loves Jesus
as a Muslim and he makes it clear that
Jesus was a Muslim now let's bring him
on to explain this
my next guests and peace be with you
pleasure to see you again Eddie good to
see you too how you been
all Praises Allah I'm doing good so you
heard me uh in the opening is there
something uh that I missed is this
correct
regarding uh Jesus Islam for our Muslim
audience
well what you said it exactly correct we
as Muslims we believe that the word
Muslim comes from the word aslama
meaning to submit and we believe Jesus
peace and blessing to be upon him was a
true Prophet a great man who submitted
his will to that of his God as he says
in the Bible he did the will of the
father meaning the god that is referred
to in the Bible so he was somebody who
was a Muslim in action he did the
bidding the work the the will of the
Creator submitting himself as a Muslim
and we in the Quran we believe all of
the prophets all the way from Adam till
the prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon all of them they were all
Muslims because they all submitted their
own will to that of their creator and
they brought that message of the Creator
the same message we believe it's always
been one message believe in God don't
worship idols don't worship anybody
except God follow the prophet of your
time if we as Muslims were there in the
time of G Jesus we would be those
disciples that would be standing right
next to him if we were in the time of
Moses we would be with him and we were
in the time of Abraham we'd be with him
as we are in the time of the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon all
of them so help us to understand better
for the uh Muslim audience out there so
because you got so many religions
it wasn't like okay in this time
excuse me you had one religion being
brought for instance Christianity and
then another religion Judaism and then
another Rhythm Hinduism and this Century
now we're going to have uh Buddhism was
it something like that
no because if you look at all of the
isms that you've mentioned they were
started by the name of somebody for
example Christianity is named after
Christ so before Jesus Christ peace and
blessings be upon him there was no such
thing as Christianity there is no
historic record that mentions
Christianity before Jesus peace and
blessings be upon him if you look at
Judaism named after Judah Confucianism
or Buddhism all of these Islams are
named but in Islam you will notice it's
not named after anybody we're not
muhammadins we are Muslim and as the
Quran talks about Abraham peace and
blessings be upon him and as you will
notice and the audience will notice when
I mention any of these prophets I out of
respect say peace and blessings be upon
them that's how much Muslims love them
you'll never see a Muslim disrespect
Jesus peace and blessings be upon him or
Moses peace and blessings be upon him
you will never see a Muslim making
caricatures or drawings or doing
anything else to hurt the image of these
great prophets we love them and we
follow them we believe in them equally
the Quran tells us that our belief in
them is equal meaning that if we reject
one it is as if we've rejected all of
them so those prophets they didn't bring
a religion to name after themselves
Jesus never told people peace and
blessings be upon him be a Christian
right we challenge Christians to bring
us any verse in the Bible or historic
record where Jesus peace and blessings
be upon Him tells his followers be
Christians no he tells them worship the
one true God the same message that we
find in the Quran to worship the one
true creator and that's why the word
Muslim is in the Quran we see that even
Ibrahim Abraham peace and blessings be
upon him he would call his Nation
Muslims because that is the ones that
submitted their will we don't believe
that there's these prophets started new
religions we don't believe the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
started Islam this is a misconception
people put Islam started in the sixth
Century with the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him no Islam has always been the
religion from the time of Adam since the
day of judgment the true religion of the
one true creator has always been Islam
and that's why if you look at the Ten
Commandments the first commandment is
here o Israel your lord is one the
second commandment don't worship idols
this is what we find in the Quran
say Allah is one the same message you
find
the the people who deviated from this
message people like Paul and those who
follow the Pauline Doctrine and others
Council of naziah given Divinity to
Jesus and so on peace and blessings be
upon him these are the people that spun
off the true one message and made their
own religions and that's why we see such
vast differences between the Judaism of
today and what Moses peace and blessings
be upon him follow if you look at
Orthodox Jews today and you even look at
their dress and you look at their forms
of worship you will find things that you
don't find in the Torah you will not
find it in the practice of Moses or
David peace be upon them as the great
prophets that there were you look at
Christians today I mean I know you come
from a background where you know
Christianity well most of the practices
we see in church are not found in the
actual practice of Jesus peace be upon
him how did Jesus pray we found that he
preached standing he prayed bowing he
prayed with his head to the ground in
the Bible till today even with all the
Corruptions and changes you will find
that he put his head his face on the
ground and prayed to God
that's how you see muslims praying
that's how the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him showed us but if you go to
churches today you see somebody kneeling
and dancing and singing and jumping and
doing backflips and all kinds of
insanity you see Orthodox Jews that take
live chickens and put them over their
head you can YouTube the videos you can
see them I found myself in an
interesting gathering in Brooklyn this
week one involving lots of chicken
swinging everyone was swinging them
older men
younger women
older couples
younger couples expecting a baby
parents wave them above their children
these are not practices that were the
practice of those actual prophets these
are all what we call Innovations people
are innovated these ways look at
Christmas right where's Christmas in the
Bible where's the 25th of December where
is Christmas where are trees we're a
gift where where are Santa Claus coming
down your chimney and all these kinds of
eggnog and all this these are all just
deviation this is based off saturnalia
which was a pagan Festival
and you can look this up yourself these
Pagan festivals were brought in to
change the true religion of Jesus peace
and blessings be upon him to
accommodate the Nordic uh pagans of
Europe
in Islam we don't believe in that we
believe in staying true to the message
that was revealed as it was revealed
till today uh for our non-muslim or
future Muslims or not yet Muslim
audiences go to a mosque anywhere in the
world and you will see the prayer being
done like the prophet showed us peace
and blessings be upon him you go get a
Quran anywhere from China to America you
open up the first chapter will be Al
Fatiha the last chapter will be enough
it will have 114 chapters 30 sections
everywhere all Muslims even different
sects we will find the same Quran
but today if you go to a Catholic church
and you pick up a Catholic Bible you
will find different numbers of chapters
you'll find Tobit and things that you
will not find in the King James version
if you find the new revised edition if
you look at the New World Translation if
you look at any of these you will find
different verses and you know on the one
message Foundation Channel we have many
videos where we show Christians these
differences and there are no responses
except that they chose what they wanted
King James and the council that he set
up they set up their own translation and
their own collection the Eastern
Orthodox Church the Roman Catholic
Church the the Ethiopian Bible they all
have differences the Greek Orthodox
Bible and I have a video where I
describe all these and I show all these
in Islam we believe in sticking to that
one true message that was revealed to
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
the same God the same creator that
revealed his message to Jesus to Moses
to Abraham peace and blessing be upon
all of them
you mentioned Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessed be upon him we know he's the
last and final measure sent to mankind
but when you bring this up to certain
people to let's say the Christians some
of them and how would you answer this
they try to compare him to like a Joseph
Smith in the Mormons who they reject
they say oh this is just another sect
just like we have the Mormons have you
heard this argument
hey baby are you an angel because I'm
allergic to feathers
you know how to get them hey baby did
you just fart because you blew me away
no matter what technology the church
comes out with you can never become the
power of the knock what is the celestial
girl like you doing in a terrestrial
place like this
that's a good one you ready for BYU BYU
I do
we hear we hear all kinds of uh
interesting points we brought up and so
on how do you like to answer that sure
so the first foremost thing is if we
look at the Mormon church and and what
was developed there and so on uh and
other sects that you have in
Christianity and false prophets and
things we show a distinction between
that and the prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings upon him in the first and
foremost the Quran
The Book of Mormon and again with no
disrespect to Mormons I have it I've
read it I've gone through it you will
find many things that are not in
accordance to what modern science has
found today you will find many things
that would be I would say racially
unacceptable for us to stay today and I
don't want to go too deep unless you
want to go down that rabbit hole no no
but but you can look at the writings of
Bingham young and you can write about
The Mark of Cain and uh how black skin
was a a curse brought and things like
this that today if you really want to
discuss
um you know you couldn't say these would
be the three teachings of a true Prophet
right you don't find any actual
historically verified Miracles you don't
find any scientific facts that
scientists Joseph Smith could not have
known at the time and found out later we
find all those miracles in the life of
the Prophet peace and blessings be upon
him first and foremost sign that shows
that he was a true Prophet is the Quran
itself we challenge Christians and say
look
tell us this how can a man in the desert
who doesn't know how to read or write
according to the historians across the
board from IBN from and you go back to
the scholars Muslims and orientalists
you will find that the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him was illiterate
unlettered couldn't read or write how
could he then write a book that was so
eloquent that none of the Poets of
Arabia could answer that none of them
could bring anything like it and they
tried I have a series on the life of the
Prophet peace and blessings be upon him
and we show evidences historic evidences
of those poets that tried and failed to
show that nobody could bring illiterate
literally work that would had such
balara excellence in speech right not
just that the Quran talks about the Sun
and the Moon and the planetary bodies
being in an orbit
you know till very recently scientists
were were saying that the sun doesn't
have an orbit I mean the Sun and very
recently they said you know it does it's
a very slower but it does have an orbit
How could a man in a desert who didn't
know astronomy who didn't have access to
the works of the Greeks and the Romans
and all of this
even the Greeks and Romans didn't know
this thing how could he have known that
okay somebody could say maybe he guessed
at it okay no problem you guess once you
get it right I got it but then you have
multiple Miracles like that scientific
facts how salt water and tea water touch
but don't mix How Mountains have pigs
that go on the ground things that he
wasn't a geologist he didn't the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him we don't have
any evidence that he ever went to a
place that had salt water what was
around him it was all Sweet Water so how
would he know there's waves under the
ocean how would he know these things how
could he guess every time and get a
driver not just that their historic
prophecy you see like like when you put
all of these together it becomes a
numeric fact that this could not have
been without divine intervention and
I'll explain this
so there's scientific miracles
then there are linguistic Miracles as we
talked about then there are prophecy
about the Romans and Persians and
battles and who would win that came true
even if you look at the Prophecies of
the Prophet Muhammad in the Quran in
Hadith where he talked about the the
victory of Constantinople today we call
it Istanbul right how would you have
known that the victories over the
Persians how would he have known that at
a time where he didn't even control the
Arabian Peninsula at the time in handak
when all the different Arab tribes were
attacking Medina there was the fear that
the Muslims would be
genocided to be finished by the Arabian
tribes he was telling them we will have
conscience and he will prophesizing
these things and those came true one
after the other every one of them how do
you guess every time and get it right
and then there are physical Miracles and
I have a video especially about this and
I think me and you spoke about this
before about the splitting of the Moon
today if we go I mean amongst the Mormon
Church they still have prophets they
have people that they call prophets
right and there are many other uh
Christian denominations that have
prophets I will I will challenge any one
of them come meet me in San Diego and
we'll go out on a clear night and I'll
point at the moon and I'll ask them
split the moon for me right can they do
it
I don't think so right the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
during his lifetime the the
polytheists of Mecca they told him show
us a miracle he said what do you want
they say split the moon and this is the
Quran in the first Ayah and he he
pointed and Allah made it that the moon
split now again this sounds like a a
very wild claim I understand but we will
bring extraordinary evidence for this
right we're not distinguished in the
Quran so we believe it no like for
example Moses split the ocean okay we
believe it but if we ask Jews to show
historic evidence we don't have it right
if you talk about Jesus walking on water
if you talk about first-hand reports
that can be verified to change of
narrations you don't have it
in Islam we will show that the people
who or eyewitnesses
who were from different cities
at this time he was in Medina now each
one of these eyewitnesses we can give
you their historic profile meaning we
can tell you what was their name their
father's name their mother's name their
children how was their memory where they
lived where were they born where did
they die how good was their Precision of
reporting we called up and all of this
right not just that who did they share
this information with who were the one
that reported from them who wrote it
down who were the scholars of Hadith not
just that these are from not just the
companions of the Prophet peace be upon
him but even the enemies of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him now imagine
Eddie if I'm in Balboa Park and I'm
having a debate and I tell guys hey you
know what I can split the moon right or
I can split the sun right maybe the
people on my side I hope not but maybe
some of them will back me just because
it's a partisan thing right
but my enemies were debating against me
no way they're going to be like we got
them finally we got him you know he
didn't do it we didn't see it right they
would make a big fuss out of it
the enemies of the Prophet peace be upon
him who were the polytheist idol
worshipers of Mecca they admitted that
yes this happened imagine that nobody
from that historical time denied it
right it's in the Quran meaning it was
recited in front of the politics for
years after that none of them said no we
were in Mecca and it didn't happen we
challenged Christians atheists Jews
Hindus whoever else to bring us one
single report of anybody from that time
period whether he was a mushrik A
polytheist or not that said no I was in
Mecca and this did not happen we will
bring multiple reports from Abu sufyan
who was not Muslim at that time from
abujah and others who never became
Muslims that died as enemies of Islam
but they still admitted yes this did
happen so how does a false prophet bring
something like this just yeah and you
have the the Mormon prophets they're
making predictions of the end of times
is going to come but then that date
comes and passes you don't have these
things with Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessed to be upon Him certainly uh I
just recently had a debate with a uh
Korean Jesus believing sect uh it's a
Christian group out of Korea that
believes that Jesus came back as a
Korean man and and and he's dead he came
and died and his wife is now God they
call her mother god
um and and they they believe that you
know he was a he was Jesus and they had
given a time that the world would end
and that time passed you know and the
world didn't end that's it discredited
discredited right and and they have all
these kinds of things but people
sometimes want to blindly follow
something we in Islam we don't blindly
fall we have clear evidences on what we
follow
so you mentioned the Miracles from the
Quran the splitting of the Moon that's
just one you have prophecies you talk
about so we often talk about the
Miracles or Christians talk about which
we believe many of the Miracles that
Jesus did peace be buses be upon him but
you can't go ahead and prove that to an
atheist or anybody like what you said a
chain uh narrators and whatnot but you
also have and you touch upon this in
your history in the life of prophet
Muhammad just touch upon this uh just
slightly again there are tremendous so
we talk about the Quran which is the
living miracle for anyone who's sincere
humble open-minded they look at it they
will come to know that this there's no
way this can come from any one other
than the creator of the heavens and
earth but you also have so how many how
many did you mention like over a
thousand Miracles three thousand we have
three thousand reports meaning each
report may not be a particular Miracle
by itself but there's three thousand
that I mentioned
um narrations that mention different
Miracles that happen during in the
lifetime of the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings and people witnessed it
this is not like yes one person to you
have how many people are witnessing
these things happen
so so these reports once again they are
not uh ambiguous reports they have to be
what we call uh
connected chains meaning that the person
who physically saw it or heard it and so
on will have to be known we have to know
who he is where he lived we know how was
his memory how was his moral character
and then everybody that he mentioned
this too we check each one of them and
we have for some of them 70 80 different
people who witnessed these who told 70
80 100 different people and who told 50
60 100 different people and then we
checked the biography each one of them
if any one of them has a weakness in
memory if any of them has a weakness in
their moral character we don't accept
that report that's a dive it's a weak
report right so we have sahih authentic
numerous chains let me give you an
example
um me and you are both from the US even
I'm currently outside the U.S but uh we
believe that there was a man named
George Washington right
I mean me and you would agree right and
your viewers would probably agree as
well
believe that he had uh you know a a
revolution against the British who were
ruling and so on and so on and he was at
this battle and that battle
but did you ever stop to think like who
was the eyewitness to any of this
right we just believe it because in our
history textbooks but who is the
eyewitness that saw George Washington
what's their name and who did they tell
this information to that I saw George
Washington at this battle leading this
way or in a Gettysburg address or if you
look at even later in history if you
look at things like you know Abraham
Lincoln the speeches he gave
we don't have a YouTube video of it we
don't have a Facebook live of it how do
we know these things actually happen
well we say you know it's in a history
book but as Muslims we don't just go by
that we have a system of and I'm going
to translate all these terms means
criticizing and ideal meaning
accrediting where we go and check each
narrator that mentions the report so if
somebody says I saw the prophet peace be
upon him and water came out of his hands
because we were in a battle and this is
actually an incident that happened we
don't just accept it because we're
Muslim and it sounds good no we say no
no no we want to be fair and just we
want to be honest we say okay who was
the one that physically saw it yes we
said Arabi like he used his senses and
who else saw it we don't if it just one
this is called Hadith right we say okay
who else saw it and how many reports do
we have okay who did they give this
information to how does that information
reach us how can we know that nobody
exaggerated that nobody cut anything out
or added anything right and then we go
to each report and each chain and know
which scholar of Hadith wrote it and how
many different Scholars wrote it and we
check each biography and when we find
something that is
so many chains that numerically it
cannot be that they came together on a
lie or a mistake then we call this this
is sure knowledge that sure we can
definitely believe in this which is a
greater level of verification than any
history book that you have today I
challenge historians on this wow this is
amazing so you mentioned one of those
Miracles was water coming from his from
Muhammad was upon his hands yes
witnessed by that numerous numerous
people numerous and
and like I said I have a series that
goes over the life of the Prophet peace
of the bad Channel and on the one
message Foundation channel in that I
give the references to the books so if
you want to know which book which volume
which page number I give reference to
all of those and as I mentioned in when
I was collecting my notes for these this
series there were around 3 000 reports
meaning Hadith some of them 30 40 Hadith
just about one incident some of them
there's a hundred Hadith about one
incident but three thousand different
reports about different Miracles
throughout the life of the Prophet peace
be upon him and these are verified that
is an excellent book called
and there is uh summarize one of that
that Jeff mukbil did it's a very very
good book it's
uh you know you can get it but this is
just one book that goes over many of the
true miracles of the life of the Prophet
peace be upon him and when we comb
through the books of History we find
many orientalists non-muslims that have
had to admit that these Miracles were
such that they could would not be faked
they could not be a trick because so
many different people saw it at so many
different times you know sometimes we
hear oh in Mexico there was a a a statue
of the Virgin Mary and it was bleeding
and yeah this report goes all out and
then they're like yeah we found there
were pipes in the bottom you know and
then everybody wants to ignore those you
know somebody finds out they were eating
uh the the bread and then they tested it
and it was Flash and they were like nah
actually those are enzymes and that's
why they tested you know these kind of
things but if you look at the the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon his
miracles there were such that you could
not fake it you can't fake splitting of
the moon this is not a magic trick and
if you did you could only fake it to the
people that were around you like like if
a great magician here does a trick and
he makes a plane disappear it's it's
trick for those that are around him now
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
during his time when the moon split the
people of embraced his tribe the people
of Mecca the polities they wanted to
challenge that so what they did and this
is in a book called
they did is they asked the people that
were outside of Mecca the Bedouin tribes
and others Travelers who were you know
on Caravan they said hey did you guys
see it and they said yes we saw it and
people like who at that time would have
been in Medina in a different city he
saw it and we have historic evidence and
I can give you the references in the
video that I have about the spreading of
the Moon if you put my name of Philip
nefaru Moon spring you'll find all of
the evidences we have evidences from
India from Mauritius again as I said we
have a science of checking that is very
stringent like if we find any conspiracy
in reports we reject we said that is and
so on so those reports cannot match our
standards but the historic reports out
of India that there were Kings in India
that saw the splitting of the Moon and
later when they met the Muslims they
accepted Islam saying we saw this
miracle and built a mosque that is still
standing today in India these have oral
reports there are written reports in
Arabic and in Portuguese and Spanish and
and British uh historians they they
compiled these reports in India it is
such a well-known fact it is such a
well-known history for them that even
the prime minister of India Mr Modi uh
when he was trying to build trade
relations with Saudi Arabia he had a
gold a small model of that mosque made
and he said this is the mosque that was
made by the Hindu king that saw the
splitting of the Moon and became a
Muslim and he gave it as a gift to the
king of Saudi Arabia I have screenshots
of his tweets where he mentions this a
enemy of Islam and we've looked at Modi
and his policies they have been very
critical against Muslims somebody who is
a right-wing Hindu extremist BJP party
even he is a testimony to the fact that
the king of India saw this putting in
the moon he admits this this is a part
of their history so now how could you
not know how could you not believe in a
miracle that was seen even by
non-muslims that didn't even know who
the prophet Muhammad peace your opponent
was at that time
until later when they were told by the
Arab who went to trade when they heard
from Malik dinar and others about what
Islam is then they became Muslims they
built mosques and we still have them
this is amazing and this is a lot of the
things from the Sierra the life of
prophet Muhammad those three thousand
you mentioned this is like as they say
the appetizers because you have the
Quran which is the living miracle and
then this on top of it so anybody again
who's sincere who wants to know who's
asking the creator of the heavens and
earth for guidance and they look at this
they God willing inshallah they'll find
that this is indeed the truth from the
creator of the heavens and earth I want
to touch upon this video here I thought
about because there's also a lot of end
of times
um statements from Prophet Muhammad one
of them which talks about and maybe you
can go ahead and bring some of these
about murder there would be so much
murder that the person wouldn't know
what he's even murdered for so I saw
this and I wanted to get your thoughts
on this because it kind of goes back and
how you can link it possibly to this
prophecy that Prophet Muhammad is
talking about the rise of murder towards
the end of time
A store owner says his heart is with his
employees after a shooting at a subway
on Northside Drive the owner says one of
his employees is dead well-rounded young
ladies really hard workers everybody
loved them the owner says the woman just
started a few weeks ago he says another
employee is injured and says one of the
employees sons was inside witnessing
everything well we had an employee I
mean a customer that came in
that was
a little upset about how his sandwiches
face believe it or not it was over too
much mayonnaise on it sounds that's when
he says oh hell broke loose he says the
man started shooting and the store
manager shot back when police arrived
the owner says they made an arrest but
he's not sure who it was we're still
working to get more information on what
happened from police as for the shooter
the owner says they've seen him before
he's a previous customer but there
haven't been any issues in the past too
much mayonnaise
too much money that's insane and this is
one of there are many signs of the day
of Judgment of the Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him told us
about that are coming crew in front of
our eyes and no doubt this is one of
them that killing will become wild wild
wild widespread and fornication I mean
if you look at fornication unmarried
people having casual sex this is
something that historically was not at
this level even if you look in Europe if
you look in America maybe let's not even
go too far back like if you go to the
50s and 40s and so on
you didn't find this to be common where
people just go and have casual sex with
anybody and everybody
um you know you had you know even like
why do brides wear white in America and
this because there was a sign of her
being a virgin and so on these Concepts
were there in Europe and in America
until very recently and now you see uh
these murders and and mass shootings and
school shootings and you know these are
all signs of the day of judgment coming
through in front of our eyes if we look
at a lot of these you know especially in
America we see these school shootings
you know these kids walk in with you
know whatever ARS or I mean it doesn't
even matter it could be with a with a
hammer or a knife or whatever and they
kill people at random and they have no
reason to kill that person I mean it's
not even like a sandwich I mean
absolutely did this child or this kid or
this teacher personally did not do
anything even if that child was bullied
it wasn't that kid
so he's killing him for no reason and
that kid has no idea why this kid is
just shooting up
right and I mean I'm not here blaming
this on guns this is this is really a
breakdown of society that that's the
issue that we're dealing with I mean we
have guns in other countries is you know
but people aren't walking around into
schools and shooting it up right
something is wrong these these signs and
then let me tell you a couple more I
mean if you look at some of the signs of
the day of judgment as a prophet peace
be upon him told us about that are
historically verified one of them is the
conquest of Jerusalem right
how could the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon have known that now imagine if the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
that the Muslims will conquer the North
Pole or something right
and then it didn't happen every
Christian would be like ah see it didn't
happen right but but look at every place
the prophet peace be upon him said would
be conquered by Muslims had happened
Constantinople Jerusalem the Persian
Empire so on you look at it it one after
the other they all came true uh they all
they all came they all came true it
wasn't like maybe five out of five no
100 out of four hundred I mean every
single one of them there is the major
fire that would happen in hijaz for
example this was one of the signs of the
day of judgment that Imam whenever we
said came true in his time and he
documented when it happened would it
happen how how the uh how the fire was
described in the Hadith and how it
happened during his time uh this is done
I mean the wide spread uh use of usury
or riba you know interest-based banking
this is something the prophet Saws
prophesied and this wasn't common before
and now you see it it has happened the
drinking of alcohol musical instruments
um one of the signs that I I find scary
and amazing is something that came
through during me and you's lifetime
which is the Shepherds and Bedouins
competing and building tall buildings
you know uh one of the places I studied
Islam was in the UAE and and there was a
city called Russell beautiful city in a
beautiful country that's had a really
good time
um and I used to study with one of the
scholars in his house
in that City there was a young man and
he told the story about his father the
father had passed away at that time but
his father was illiterate he never
learned how to read or write he owned a
good amount of land in Russian
and once the economic boom of oil and
happened in UAE and they developed a
country of UAE and so on
um they built buildings on his land so
he personally loved the Bedouin
lifestyle he couldn't read or write
didn't want to go back to school he they
had a mansion but he would put a tent
outside and he would sleep in the tent
he enjoyed that lifestyle and he didn't
like cars so he would he would he would
go around the city in a donkey that was
what he was used to so he was he owned
buildings tall buildings but he couldn't
read or write he was an illiterate
Bedouin with a flock of sheep but you
know Allah gave him that wealth so he he
built buildings and he would go to these
buildings and he would collect the rents
and he couldn't read or write so he
would just tell them he swear about
Allah this is the correct rent and they
would say yes and he was like okay
and this is one of the signs of the day
of Judgment at the illiterate Bedouin
Shepherds would be competing in building
tall buildings today I believe seven of
the ten and you know it fluctuates
sometimes with new buildings of the
tallest buildings in the world are in
the Middle East those people who for a
generation ago were Bedouins now are
competing literally in trying to build
one mile into the sky
this is a truly amazing I was watching a
documentary the other day it was called
the everyone was recommending it it was
called the what is a woman
and they had one part it was there in
California I think that's where you're
from and I wanted I wanted to ask you
because they had it blurred out but they
actually had men naked men walking in
the street is this really happening in
California
I mean
um
fortunately I'm from San Diego and San
Diego is not as
bad as other parts of California
um we don't have something like this
that I have seen in San Diego personally
but there are areas in California
where definitely this is going on isn't
that against the law indecent exposure
has the law been changed
you know to be honest with you I don't
even know the lies anymore right I mean
now they have a law in some parts of
California that if you shop like under a
thousand dollars and can't arrest you so
you got people walking out five hundred
dollars six hundred dollars worth of
stuff and the police is giving them
tickets
um I I mean doing drugs I thought was
against the law but now if you go to
certain parts of California you will see
people smoking meth or heroin or
marijuana like it's nothing like weeds
not even thing anymore like like you
know like back in my days or I don't
know I mean I'm sure in your days in
high school that was like a rebellious
thing like always smoking weed you know
now teachers are like
in the classroom
I mean you know it's legal yeah so
what's this I hear what you're saying
yeah but but now it's become worse now
you see people doing heroin like it's
nothing you see people smoking mouth you
see uh I mean now the it's become to
such a level
that I don't even know what the law is
anymore like I don't know what do we
enforce I mean the homeless population
has become such a problem in California
and around the world and especially in
the U.S
uh I don't know what we're going to do
with the country because now you have a
person who just set up a tent in the
middle of a street I mean that's illegal
right because it's a walkway and then 30
40 other tents will be put up and then
they'll have their own little Society
they'll be sitting there in broad
daylight doing all kinds of drugs
um you know
police walks by and doesn't do anything
you know let me ask you you heard about
the Chapel Hill uh what happened in
Chapel Hill day it's called Chas or the
of the free zone that they took over
where some people you know whether they
were antifa or not I'm not going to get
into the politics of it but they there
were like four city blocks or something
like that that they with weapons took
over and made it an autonomous zone for
a while right and the police had to
leave the mayor said to the police leave
I want to do a social experiment that if
you're ready I'm ready right me and you
and we're going to bring a bunch of our
Muslim Brothers with beards and turbans
and shimas and we're going to get AK-47s
and let us take over a few blocks and
say you can't enter
let's see how long that lasts you know
the racism or the double standards will
come out real quick with that one right
yeah but that's why I said I don't know
what
of a group of protesters takes over a
block and says the police can't enter
but they're of a certain you know
whatever demographic then that's okay uh
you know if I want to self-identify as a
woman today and walk into a bathroom you
know and you're gonna have security
called on me why but somebody else does
it then it's okay I don't know it's a
strange world we live in but you know
one thing I'll tell you learn about
signs of their judgment something that
hit me the other day or I was talking to
my neighbor
and we're talking about yoga pants and
as Muslim women obviously alhamdulillah
they cover when they go outside and so
on
um a lot of women have this thing now
today where they walk around in the
street wearing what they're called yoga
pants which are really really skin tight
I mean again if you wear it in the
privacy of your home or when you're
working out in a place where there's
only women and that's a different issue
but if you're walking on the street you
know this is something strange because
what if you still have what if you saw
the top part the hijab yeah I think
people misunderstand what the word hijab
means hijab doesn't mean cover your head
they just have means to conceal so if
you have a little scarf on with yoga
pants you're not concealing much and my
neighbor who's not Muslim he told me you
know I don't like these yoga pants and I
was like why he said because it doesn't
leave much to the imagination wow
immediately immediately the Hadith or
the prophet peace be upon Him came to me
the prophecy the prophecy of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon the Miracles
another miracle another miracle wow that
women would be covered but be naked
honey and this is what we see today
these this could not have been known by
the companion of the Prophet peace be
upon him the early generation the
Muslims could not have imagined that
there would be clothing that is so tight
that if you get a goosebump it shows and
and that's what we're seeing in our time
this prophecy coming true in front of
our eyes let me ask you this is it a far
stretch you know you know the where God
Almighty Allah is talking about when the
female baby when she is brought back and
asked for what crime was she murdered
today there's a big debate you know now
with the overturning of the abortion
with the road
have you followed this have you kind of
up to speed
you know for for let's say a child or a
a baby who sex is now determined in the
womb can you is it a long stretch to go
ahead now and to connect it where
because you have even some Muslims now
in this state who are confused or maybe
they have some leaders also who are you
know promoting this
my daughter today texted me she's in
Minneapolis she's 19.
and she said
mom is there is this it
is this it
is there nothing
that can be done
I cried after I read that text message
and it's hard for me to admit that
because I don't like telling people like
that
but I sat there
so we're recognizing
that for 13 states
in the United States
that after 30 days
this is it
and for another 13.
is going to also be dead
and it could be it for 50 if we do not
act and how what's the Islamic position
regarding abortion because this is an
area where you can say that Christians
and Muslims there is a common
understanding on this the fight for for
human for Life the size of a 20-week
baby
is the size of the length of my hand
from the head to the rump not including
the feet the average baby at this
gestation will weigh 500 grams
the suction machine will remove from
around the baby the pale yellow amniotic
fluid that has been surrounding and
protecting the baby now with babies this
big they won't fit through a suction
catheter the baby's bones and skull are
quite strong they cannot be torn apart
by the suction alone
the instrument used to carry out the
termination of pregnancy is a forceps a
grasping forceps it is a metal high
quality instrument
uh 13 inches or so in length the active
end of the instrument is about two and a
half inches in length and it has teeth
within the instrument which when it
grasps a structure
will not let it go easily the
abortionist uses this clamp to grasp an
arm or a leg
once he has a firm grip the abortionist
pulls hard in order to tear the limb
from the body of the baby
one by one the rest of the limbs are
removed along with other body organs the
intestines the spine the heart and the
lungs usually the most difficult part of
the procedure is extracting the baby's
head because at this stage of pregnancy
the baby's head will be the size of an
average Plum it simply won't come
through the cervix in order that this is
removed
one needs to crush the skull
this requires inserting the grasping
forceps and placing it around the head
and crushing the baby's head
that will of course
cause damage
an injury to the skull bones
and one will know that one has achieved
that by observing a yellowish creamy
fluid moving through the cervix that
will be the brains of the baby the
abortionist then will collect the
various parts of the body and reassemble
them to check that there are two arms
two legs and so on once all the parts
have been accounted for the abortion
procedure is complete for the woman this
procedure carries significant risks
major complications can occur including
perforation of the uterus or laceration
of the cervix with possible damage to
the bladder the bowel and other maternal
organs infection and Hemorrhage can also
occur and is not rare these
complications can lead to massive
Hemorrhage septicemia and include death
future pregnancies are also a greater
risk for loss because of premature
delivery due to abortion related trauma
and injury to the cervix and uterus
what I have described is an operation
that will be done from
14 weeks of pregnancy through to 24
weeks of pregnancy it's very gruesome
the reality of abortion particularly the
second trimester is very gruesome
then you have another side but there's
obviously obviously there's the
exceptions right you can talk about that
but what's the what's the Islamic stance
on this abortion
Islam is a religion that is a divine
religion meaning it's a religion that
was revealed uh from the Creator so we
have a balance that you don't find in
anything man-made right so in essence
human life has to be protected right and
the child in the womb past the first
stage the first trimester you could say
and so on it is alive there is a beating
heart that is flesh that is thought that
is a brain
um in Islam we don't believe that it's
okay for somebody to murder that child
as a form of contraceptive you know as a
form of you know what I I didn't use
whatever protection so now I'm going to
murder this child what fault is it of
that child right we don't believe that
at the same time there are certain times
because Islam is a very practical and
balanced religion that there could be an
exception to the rule in the sense that
maybe the life of the mother is in
danger the life of the child and the
mother are in danger there are some
pregnancies that we can in a
professional medical doctors can say
that both the child and the mother would
be in danger of their life if this went
forward and then you would look at how
far the pregnancy is and you have a
whole system in Islam to determine that
one of the calamities of our time is
Muslim politicians are not looking at
what is right from wrong they're not
looking at moral code they're not
looking at the Quran they're not looking
at the Sunnah they're not looking at the
Sharia they're not looking at what is
the Divine Message of Islam they're
looking at political alliances
and this is a Calamity and we saw this
coming early on when mosque started to
have political parties and started to
have politicians come and give speeches
and they started to have Muslims get
involved with Democrats and Republicans
in this party and that party I used to
raise the red flag and say look you guys
are talking about a Muslim you're
talking about a need of greater good but
you realize this is going to take you
down a path where you're going to become
part of that system where if you are in
a certain political party you're going
to have to stand for certain principles
just to keep your position in that party
in America is not and we talk about a
free country in the sense anybody can
become president but really you can't I
mean if we're being honest there's two
parties this is the you've never seen a
green party or libertarian or anybody
even come close and not In Our Lifetime
right so you have Republicans and
Democrats and these are the two parties
that if you're going to have a president
one of those two parties and to get to
where you can even get to that platform
to be able to run you have to fall in
line with their principles not your
Islamic principles not your Christian
principles not your Jewish principles
not your uh Buddhist principles you have
to be in line with there so you will see
people who are Christians who are
Catholics who are Muslims but because
they have a certain letter whether it's
a r or a D in front of their candidate
name they will sacrifice their religious
principles for these uh political goals
right Biden for example he's a Catholic
right
and the Catholic Church according to
their Doctrine are against abortion but
Biden he's pro-russian wide because
politics and our Muslim brothers and
sisters may Allah protect us and protect
them we make Dua for them we're not here
to attack people we're here to uh honey
supplicate for them and for their good
and to protect our ummah from their
mistakes are falling down that same
mistake they are taking political
stances sacrificing the Sharia and I
want to be very clear as a Muslim we
have to live by the Quran what Allah has
revealed in accordance with the way of
the Prophet peace and blessings be upon
him and we have to live by that Divine
code and if we
overturn or try to do away with even a
letter even a single ruling knowing that
this is the ruling from Allah and we go
against it not that we make a mistake or
sin everybody sins but we say no this
Haram this forbidden thing is
permissible or this permissible thing is
forbidden this will take you outside the
fold of Islam this is something that
takes you outside the fall of Islam
Allah has forbid killing Allah says that
I have forbidden foreign
oppression on myself and on you so don't
oppress each other I he has forbid us
from killing in the Quran it tells us
killing One Soul unjustly it's like
killing all of mankind so a
five-month-old fetus that is you know
has teeth and all of that and you abort
it for what for what reason oh I don't
feel like having a baby today it was
getting wasn't it getting to the point
where it was uh six months in seven
months in eight months in not four full
term brought to look and they were still
doing this yeah I mean the issue is when
we talk about terms and we talk about
abortion even even when we look at the
the the reasons for it it shocks me
sometimes there's a message but the
thing is my body my choice
well that's that's interesting when we
say that my body my choice so you know
when you have a you know five six month
old child in your stomach
what about that child's body and their
choice you know is that not a human
being
you know this is something amazing to me
that and think about this all these
people making these statements imagine
if their parents had done that imagine
if me and you and may Allah protect us
all if my parents had said you know my
body my choice but you know for what
there is no risk to health there's no if
you think you can't provide for a child
remember Allah is the one that provides
how many children are born and raised in
orphanages and end up becoming
Millionaires and billionaires you know
Steve Jobs for example his dad wasn't
there he had whatever and his dad left
didn't raise him and he was one of the
richest men in the world right many
people like this you will find from very
humble beginnings where even Obama for
example his dad left his mother raised
him as a single mother and all of that
he became the president United States so
don't think that oh I can't afford to
have a baby you're not the one that
provides for the baby Allah writes the
risk Allah is the one that provides
sustenance if somebody thinks that oh I
can't afford a baby then the whole
mindset is wrong right if you ever look
at a bird what happens they go out in
the morning from their nest and they go
and search and come back with worms and
their stomach is full who provides for
them you look at whales and you look at
sharks in the ocean who provides for
them Allah provides for them Allah will
provide for the child that's not an
issue with people that murder children
that are for many months into it where
they have developed a heartbeat they've
developed limbs they've developed this
is murder this is not acceptable in
Islam it's not acceptable in
Christianity it's not acceptable in
Judaism it's not acceptable in any ISM
no religion in the world allows this and
people who want to go by that it's not
about I mean again I'm not trying to get
into the political divide of pro-choice
and pro-life and things this is just
basic morality this is basic Islamic and
Christian uh and Judaism basic ethical
moral code that's in the Divine text we
cannot kill children because we just
don't feel like having a baby that day
hmm and yeah
I want what were you gonna say
I just wanna again once again uh as a
reminder to my Muslim brothers and
sisters this is not about political
lines I'm not saying Democrats and
Republicans but as a Muslim we must
understand that Allah and his Prophet
salaam has forbidden such actions and as
Muslims we can never go against the
Quran and Sunnah there is a very
beautiful Hadith and I will mention this
when a woman came to the prophet peace
be upon him and told him I have
fornicated and I imagine the the the the
the fate of this woman that she is
coming forward herself I mean she's not
afraid to take the punishment right she
says oh prophet of Allah punish me I
have fornicated so the prophet peace be
upon him first he tried to tell her
maybe you have it and he because he was
so uh loving and merciful upon the
Believers but when she was very explicit
about it he said okay go back come back
when you are when you know whether
you're pregnant or not and when she came
back and she said I was pregnant he told
her it's not that child's fault imagine
this this is a child from fornication
from a sin but the prophet peace be upon
him it's not the child's fault come back
when you've delivered the baby and when
the baby was born he says come back when
you have breastfed the baby
I mean imagine even through fornication
the prophet I'm saying you can't kill
this baby it's not the baby's fault
right so
look at look at the abortion debate
today in the light of this How can any
Muslim be pro-abortion like I said in
Islam we do have checks and balances
we're not unrealistic like some
Christians and others uh we do believe
that if the life of the mother or the
child is in danger depending on what and
how far developed in the books of
discuss this in detail the books of
Jewish students
we do have exceptions because there are
times where we have to save a life right
whether it's the life of the mother or
so on
but when there is no such medical need
when there is no such life threatening
scenario to just use abortion to kill
children who are past the first
trimester this is murder this is where
we would say this is unacceptable by the
moral code of Islam and every Muslim has
to stand against that no matter their
political Alliance you think uh before
we conclude just a couple more questions
do you think this is an excuse for a lot
of people just to go and continue on
that rampant way that we talked about
earlier in the promiscuity the
fornication that's just prevalent this
is just you know kind of a card that's
there available and now that doors has
been closed you know this is what's
upsetting to a lot of people
uh I mean the door is not closed even I
mean raw uh versus Wade being overturned
doesn't mean that you're not gonna have
abortions anymore people have tried to
make it as if abortions banned but
certain late trimester abortions are
going to be left up to the state first
off so many liberal states are still
going to continue so it's still it's
still for people no it's just leaving it
up to the state to determine that
exactly I mean people have made this as
if like oh you know the government's
intruding on your price it's really not
all I mean if you really look at the
essence of the issue is the Supreme
Court has said look this is not
something the federal government should
mandate that this is a right for people
to have abort late-term abortions we're
going to leave it up to the states and I
believe the last time I mean I'm
traveling right now but last time I
checked only 15 states were going to
actually take the uh stance that you
shouldn't have late-term abortions the
rest of the states we're going to leave
it as it is and that may change but in
the end I mean even if you're in one of
those States you could go to the other
state and get an abortion so it's not
like people are like as if some great
you know it's more symbol all like
really than anything else but what
disturbs me is you have Muslim
politicians out there saying that they
are pro-abortion that they are they are
pro
somebody having a late term abortion
without any medical need meaning that
they want to say that if you just went
and had a one-night stand and you didn't
take the precautions that you could have
to stop from pregnancies happening and
then you got pregnant and then you had
that early time to stop the pregnancy
and you didn't and now you have a child
with a heartbeat flesh bones eyes you
know sometimes teeth and all of that
which develops and later trimesters and
now you want to murder that child
because you don't want to give up your
lifestyle of you know Carefree living
uh no muslim can support that what about
a statement like no one should be forced
to continue a pregnancy no one should be
forced to continue a pregnancy
right but but that's an incorrect
statement because in Islam if there is
no threat to the woman's life even if
the child was born of fornication the
prophet peace be upon him told her you
have to continue that pregnancy
so how can you go against something that
is clear in Hadith
as a Muslim yeah it's not acceptable or
as a Christian or as a Jew I mean no
faith that I know of allows such a thing
nobody that believes in God in any form
or manner believes in such a thing
and as beautiful Islam is a complete way
of life the blueprint for life it has
everything there and one of the most
precious things is life and that life in
the womb is a life
so that also is something that one is
going to have to be accountable to to
the creator of the heavens and earth on
the day of judgment so we really got to
take this serious and not fall into
these traps and I want to thank you very
much very much for uh spending some time
with us what were we going to say I I
appreciate your time really I love your
show
um support your show and you know uh
I'll tell you this um we are living in a
very strange time and a time where the
faith of people is being tested as
Muslims were watching this show as
future Muslims that are watching this
show
um understand something
people that deviated from their message
brought the curse of Allah upon
themselves the people of lot if you look
in the Bible if you look in the Quran if
you look in history they had a message
to live a certain way when they deviated
from that they were destroyed they
brought the punishment of Allah upon
themselves and
continuously we find this when you find
those that change the message that sell
out the religion for political gain for
money for monetary for for societal
pressures they destroyed themselves as a
nation and then they destroyed
themselves as individuals by dying on a
state of kufar and Shirk and I mean
Allah protected I mean the wife the wife
of lot as we find in the Quran
she is called an example of a
disbelieving woman even though she
didn't worship idols I mean it's not
that she what did she do she was from
those that turned back she supported the
lgbtq XYZ lifestyle and supported those
people against the Commandments of God
and because of that support she's called
the Catherine the Quran as a
non-believer right as somebody who
denies and rejects we as Muslims must
not let this happen we cannot support
that which Allah has forbidden clearly
in the Quran the Quran mentions the
people of lot the clear authentic
narrations from the prophet peace be
upon him they mentioned the curse of
Allah is upon those who men who dress
like women or women they're dressed like
men the trans that we're seeing today
the the the the condemnation of the act
of homosexuality is clear there is no
disagreement amongst Muslim Scholars
people like Ibrahim and others
have documented
census of the Muslim Scholars that the
act of homosexuality is forbidden
anybody that says that they're pro-lgbtq
XYZ or whatever and and and and puts
forward legislation supporting such
actions is taking themselves outside the
fold of Islam I'm not making Tech feel
here I'm saying this is this action is
known to be from those that take you
outside the fall of Islam to make
permissible that which Allah has made
Haram and to support it and to promote
it Muslims you cannot sell out the
religion for political gain you will not
Prosper this way help of Allah will not
come from you sending out the religions
if you want the help of Allah if you
want the ummah to prosper we need to
stick to the Quran we need to stick to
the Sunnah we need to go back and look
at the where the salaf the earlier
generations
and stay on their way as they were the
ones who were successful
and as non-muslims future Muslims I want
you to see that we as Muslims will not
sell out our religion even if you have
one or two here and there
as a Muslim body as a Muslim Nation we
are together and standing firm for our
religion we will not do what the
Christians did with Christianity and
bring Christmas and and all these
Innovations we will not do what the Jews
did by changing the laws of usury and so
on we will stick to our true message and
we invite you to become Muslims and
stand firm with us on that Divine
message
and just to to note uh if a Christian is
following the Bible and uh Jew is
following his teachings this is what
you're saying is clear there it's
lucidly clear also what you had just
mentioned isn't it in Christianity and
Judaism
if we look in Leviticus I
don't know sexuality is an Abomination
Mr President the Bible does yes it does
Leviticus 18 22 chapter and verse it
wasn't until I read the Bible cover to
cover at age 17 that I discovered the
truth of what the bible really says
because a lot of passages don't ever get
preached from the pulpit because they're
simply not popular you know I preach
what the Bible says and what the Bible
says is not popular I am not saying that
this is something that uh you know
should be taken as Christian law today
that's up to them to discuss but uh from
a Biblical perspective this is in the
Bible this is in the Bible this is in
the Bible that the punishment of
homosexuality is the Bible is again it
God's organic I'm against sodomy has
always been an Abomination both all the
New Testament has always been in God's
view punishable by death said he was
clearly and severely condemned from The
Book of Leviticus chapter 18 verse 22
the word of God says you shall not lie
with a male as with a woman it is an
Abomination now many people will come
back and say oh that's the Old Testament
well as Christians and Jews you do
believe the Old Testament is from God so
that would be applicable but even if you
want to look at the New Testament in
Romans they mention a list of those
things that will bring death as a
punishment and you shall not pity them
you shall not feel sorry for them and
one of them in the New Testament in
Romans is a man laying with a woman as a
with another man as he would lay with a
woman meaning the act of homosexuality
it is forbidden in the New Testament if
you look at the church fathers if you
look at historic writing from rabbis and
Priests no doubt that every religion
condemned this action we as people who
believe in God have to be able to have
the freedom of speech to be able to say
what we believe I believe
that marriage is
not just a bond but a sacred bond
between a man and a woman
the cancer culture that wants to silence
us is against the First Amendment if
somebody has the right to
dress up a man to dress up as a woman in
America and walk around and a woman
dress up as a man because they say this
is freedom then how is it that me as a
Muslim I don't have the freedom to say I
don't agree with that behavior
how
that's my question
yeah so this is uh this is very
important especially we just did some
programs on this when it's being pushed
on the children when it's being pushed
and now you as a parent you don't have a
right to say anything so
um you have your way we have ours at the
end of the day and we can go ahead
apparently I'm in I'm in Europe and and
I would say it's worse here than it is
in America uh you know this this is not
something
we look at the poem of Luke the people
of lot whether you're looking at the
biblical narrative or the one in the
Quran
um they didn't just stop at doing these
actions they forced it if you look at
the Romans and the Greek and what
happened in their you know in their spas
and whatever they wanted to call them
um this is not something that's gonna
just be like okay let us do what we want
it's going to be forced on people and
it's going on right now right now you
don't have the right to say you know
what I don't want my children being
exposed to this until I'm ready to
discuss it with them no in their
kindergartens in their preschools in
their elementary schools this is being
forced down their throat by every
narrative is being Rewritten now every
Marvel
Story movie is being Rewritten to bring
these things into it characters in in
comic books like Loki and others are
being Rewritten to be shown as whether
it's homosexual or bisex or this or that
so that the narrative can change history
is being Rewritten in front of us people
are bringing things that we never saw
why because they want this to be stuffed
down our throats they want children and
and the and and the sad thing is Muslims
or Christians who are Church growing and
Jews who are in their synagogues are
starting to fall prey to this where
they're afraid to speak up or they're
afraid to say anything because they will
get canceled what happened to freedom of
speech is it only when you insult a
religion that when that's when you have
freedom of speech but when we want to
defend our faith and say what we believe
and we have the right to believe a right
that Allah gave us that now we're being
told you're going to get canceled you're
going to get this you know what they can
cancel whatever they want we're going to
speak the truth and if enough of us
Stand Together Christians and Muslims
and Jews and Believers in God
to stand on what all of us do agree on
that this is a lifestyle that is not
acceptable a killing of late trimester
children before no medical reason is not
acceptable then we can stand together
thank you very much for being with us
may God Almighty Allah reward you
inshallah we can connect again sometime
in the future it was a pleasure and it's
always a pleasure and look look forward
to speaking to you again
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedenshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you
dear brothers and sisters alhamdulillah
I've had the blessing of knowing brother
Eddie since he started the dean show and
he's one of the most sincere and most
dedicated people to the dawah that I
have ever met and I'm so happy and
pleased to see that they are now moving
to the dean Center inshallah and I have
no doubt that this will be a successful
project inshallah so please do support
the dean Center and continue to support
the dean show